[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
torten wird heute gibt es wieder aus
türkisches von mir
ihr wart ja alles so begeistert von
meinen typischen brötchen von den
abschluss
die habe ich ja damals mit einer käse
führung gemacht und heute möchte ich
euch einfach mal eine andere variante an
füllung bieten ich mache heute eine
hackfleisch füllung die genauen
mengenangaben könnt ihr dann in meinem
blog nachlesen
ich werde die menge nämlich jetzt für
die doppelte menge an treib machen das
rezept braucht ihr euch ja nicht mehr zu
geben das könnt ihr in dem anderen video
nachschauen ich verlinke euch das
einfach unten hinter infobox und wenn
ihr jetzt wissen wollt wie man diese
brötchen herstellt oder besser gesagt
wie man die füllung herstellt da bleibt
jetzt dran ich sage ich jetzt einmal die
zutaten für die hackfleisch bildung
braucht ihr hackfleisch ich nehme die
rinder hackfleisch dann braucht ihr eine
große zwiebel knoblauchzehen paprika
markt es gibt im türkischen laden dass
ich jetzt scharf ihr braucht tomatenmark
und dann gewürze wie salz und pfeffer
ich nehme noch etwas cayennepfeffer und
paprika und noch 1 1 bis 2 gemüsebrühe
würfel und wenn ihr habt könnt ihr auch
noch frische kräuter nehmen wie
petersilie basilikum und alles was euch
schmeckt und zum anbraten nämlich ein
olivenöl
da gebe ich jetzt ein bisschen in die
pfanne lasst die heiß werden und web.de
fleisch darin anbraten und den derzeit
kümmere ich nicht so lange auf die
zwiebel in die pfanne 30 kommt da das
hackfleisch rein
und jetzt scharf angebraten
das schmerzt so lange wie du noch schön
sein
[Musik]
da schon anfängt zu knistern kommt noch
knoblauch und zwiebeln und das wird
jetzt schon weiter gegangen
wenn es dann soweit ist kommt da
tomatenmark rein irgendetwas paprika mit
antworten
dann kommt da ein schluck wasser rein
und begriffe die nächste brücke
ich mache jetzt mal so einen und kann ja
später abschmecken
karrieren pfeffer weist gerne etwas
schaffen das paprikapulver jetzt noch
kräuter der provence mit rein weil ich
keine frischen kräuter dahab scheint
jetzt auch die pfanne runter wenn ihr
merkt ist wird zu trocken wo ich noch
mal ein schuss wasser und ich geb doch
meinen zweiten bewerb uhr ein als noch
etwas zu wenig listig wenig dann nochmal
abgeschmeckt habt könnt ihr den herd
ausschalten und die füllung etwas
abkühlen lassen
dann ist endlich soweit fertig den teig
habe ich ja wie gesagt schon vorbereitet
jetzt portion ich mit den genau wie auch
bei macho dazu einfach die hände ein
bisschen einfetten und schlicht
vergessen die arbeitsfläche einzieht
dann könnt ihr euch da einfach stückchen
entnehmen oder etwas ab ich mache da
jetzt 50 gramm stückchen habe ich mir
den teig portioniert und kann die
brötchen jetzt somit befüllen
ich mache das jetzt einfach mal anders
nicht wie bei den arsch neuer diese
runde schneckenform sondern ich öffne
den teig mit etwas fett an den händen
müsste er machen sonst geht es nämlich
stark dann kommt da ein guter teelöffel
fleisch füllung reist und dann werde ich
das hier oben wo einmal umschlagen und
die enden schön verschießen so nach
innen klappen und dann lege ich das
sowohl brauchst mich also mit der nach
oben
das ganze nochmal so theike öffnen
[Musik]
ein löffel füllung ein dann einmal
umklappen
hier oben nach innen schatten und hier
auch nach innen starten und dann einfach
umgedreht aufs blech wenn ihr dann
fertig seit sie das in etwas so aus so
dass sich dieses noch mal an einem
warmen ort gehen und danach werden sie
mit eigelb und milch gestrichen und
gebacken und insgesamt habe ich jetzt
zwei bleche gemacht hier seht ihr jetzt
dass dieses fleisch schon schön
aufgegangen ist das hier muss jetzt noch
aufgehen
und jetzt werde ich aber schon mal
dieses schlecht hier mit der gelb milch
masse bestreichen
[Musik]
könnt ihr wenn ihr wollt noch etwas
schwarzkümmel oder saison drüberstreuen
und dann können dass wir bei 200 grad
backen bis die oberfläche chrom glänzt
wenn die brötchen gebacken sind sehen
sie so aus und damit sie jetzt schön aus
damme für könne
kommt da ein geschirrtuch drüber und so
lasse ich die abkühlen und dann können
sie gegessen werden
interessiert gibt es ganz viele
verschiedene möglichkeiten zu einer
hackfleisch bildung herzustellen dass
ich jetzt meine möglichkeit so gefällt
mir am besten und so schmeckt mir am
besten ich mag es nämlich ganz gern dass
die füllung würzig schmeckt und wenn
euch das rezept gefällt dann macht doch
gerne nach und dann wünsche ich euch
viel spaß beim nachmachen und hoffe ihr
seid das nächste mal wieder dabei und
wir sehen uns dann wieder bis zum
nächsten mal tschüss
[Musik]